And everybody Dr. Connor is again
Try to answer some of the most common questions that we get how do we know if it's working okay to do this alternative thing
How do I know if it's getting I'm getting better how what's the judgment call? What are the objective things that I'm looking for
Well, should I still do CT scans MRIs pet scans x-rays should I still be following what my oncologist is telling me the answer is
Yes
But they also answer also the correct answer is maybe so I'm a big fan of not doing invasive tests
Unless it's gonna change the way you treat the patient now if you're still doing chemotherapy or you're still planning
Surgery or you're still doing radiation or immuno therapy
Yes, you should still be following the recommendations of your oncologist if he's asking you to do
He or she's asking to do MRIs or CT scans to see and judge how your current therapy is working
There's a place for that but remember a CT scan a regional CT scan carries about as much rad radiation
As 50 chest x-rays. It's a lot of radiation MRIs are not
void of
Invasiveness either if you're using a die like aniline or something like that then there's issues with that too
So there's a place for imaging. I'm all for imaging. It gives us more defined answer
So if you had a CT scan that measured your mass at
You know 3.6 centimeters
Well the only way to know if that's getting better is to do the same thing to you have to compare apples to apples
So it only makes sense if you want to know if that
Mass is improving shrinking or at least stay in the same size
You have to do the same tests that you did that you measured it in the first place
Now there are some
Some less invasive ways to test you can do an ultrasound in some cases like with breast cancer
There's a tuber marker test which are blood tests. Maybe your doctor has already run those you could use those as your marker as your objective
marker now understand a lot of patients that come to us might be on the scale of they're still working with their oncologists
They're gonna get CT scans a lot of our patients too are like on the other side of the scale where I don't even care anymore
I can even do any tests as long as I know I'm feeling better and
You might be somewhere in the middle. I like a just objective testing
But I also want to respect a person who's saying I'm done all I need to know is if
I could jump on the tractor and plow the field and I can you know live my life then I don't even care anymore
I'm done with going down that pathway. I get that so everybody's a little different
We can definitely order
Tuber marker tests if you've not had those those are simply blood tests
I have a blog post on that search the website and you can see the blog post on the different tumor marker tests some cancers
Don't show tumor markers at all. Even if it's a cancer like breast cancer or colon cancer that typically shows to our markers
Some people's cancer doesn't give off to our markers. So we could run those
It's very not invasive to get a blood test
Also tell people to measure objective tests with also subjective signs
So your signs and symptoms that you're you know that you're currently experiencing if you're feeling great
But they're telling you have stage 4 cancer, whether you can't use this
But if you have symptoms
Let's say pain or fatigue or or nausea or something you can usually tell if those symptoms start to go away
And you start to feel better you have more energy that you can have a pretty good clue that you're doing better
Some people totally judge their cancer that way how you decide to do that is your choice
Again, I said I like testing because I like to see objective data
But I know that a lot of testing is invasive and carries within some level of
Invasiveness so not everybody's wanting to do that so everybody has to make their choice will help you walk through that choice